yeah welcome to this video playing
endless fighter from Bangladesh right
yes was fed he doesn't have a name in I
always ask myself without my beam really
a good player okay Queens gambit let's
see he is playing the server goes in
variation I don't really have a great
line against that it's also a very
decent choice for for black just III
probably see five yeah how how do how do
white players handle this nowadays and
really forgot it maybe you can place you
for now possible
yeah I just forgot the theory here but
ok there's not much to forget because I
didn't know so much in the first place
hi this is a dis game I possibility Roxy
one so is it possible to get this Knight
e5 at f/4 set up established okay this
is in fact interesting he wants to play
nitey form okay probably need to take
them
and it was really a doing so the
question is now what about this a three
on what about be three actually very
tricky ok if you don't know [ __ ]
guidelines it's hard to figure out at
the end I decided for Bishop e2 to f3 as
a possible setup I wonder if you can
okay if you take c3 I can take this
happen using the intermediate move it
takes five de 525 I thought 95 kin to me
yeah I thought this would be a would be
about equal he's got this idea of using
his majority but b5 ever before but I
should have some some play as long
yeah this prevents rupee one good move
my ideas bishop d 12 c 2
and for once I'm I have played in
halfway decent speed
yeah very strong I'm just preventing
this okay so i probably need to switch
plans IAM no actually threatening to
take or b-five
hmm yeah
yeah I am but is this how great is this
we'll see porn but this is not not so
easy every
or should I go g3 moon g3 looks Lak ugly
but f3 is ugly as well Kim
check oh very very difficult game maybe
yeah bishops it to where I need to
defend him before is the the idea now
trying to undermine the spawn
yep you maybe get the a four part I need
to be quick this is a strange Ruth and
then we'll get three wow I take now yeah
it's definitely better so maybe i can i
can try to I can I ask a group d 3 as
well okay right okay because rock d
three echo be 20 kev 88
much else cannot allow Jeffrey check
check Darryl blackest winning I work
this exact right okayed it doesn't
matter it was it was lost anyway all
right white resides yeah yeah looks like
him he always kept the pressure on
we should be of it I don't think what
should we be much worse en sorcerer but
it's it needs to be played very very
precisely this yeah this is very
interesting be sure before is even
stronger what I missed this i need to
play Bishop f3 myself to make sure that
he doesn't provoke any weaknesses for
example if i go here let's say attacking
this then this position is perfectly
alright you can do this but after this
there is not much going on i mean this
is the second play it's not not the end
of the world in the game this weakness
is serve is the problem when I defended
this sir quite check why dweller thought
king is sadness of course very good
kini 7am just activating an egg it's not
much I can do dad is very strong king
salmon check I now look at vaidya three
up that's very very good yeah sorry yeah
I played an excellent game Ian and I
needed to really go to sugar 3 so this
is not great for white or anything but
it was still ok but I must play Bishop
f3 otherwise and worse which you very
nice yeah yeah thanks for watching